il ya quelqu'un qui va être en régie
quelqu'un qui est en place et dans cette
émission qu'on va faire partir dans un
instant il ne sait pas où il va partir
pendant le prime
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ne regrettera pas vous verrez ça
dans un instant un instant on ira
chercher quelqu'un en régie qui va
partir en camion avec différentes
personnes il ne sait pas où on va partir
mais vous verrez je pense que ça va lui
faire plaisir
je voudrais qu'on aille chercher le
patron de davy de celle au directeur
général de débiter xavier gandon en
régie il ya des amis qui vont aller le
chercher en régie je crois qu'on a une
caméra voilà qui est prête et xavier
gandon voilà alors il
tous les coups le patron le patron jade
et guesdon va partir avec la paix pas
nicole on va le retrouver
non monsieur on va le retrouver on va le
retrouver à bâle
m
alors c'est le grand patron de des buts
il va partir car c'est son anniversaire
c'est lui le patron de débiter les trois
ans c'est vous qui avez trois ans que
saviez grande eau voilà bah ouais ça et
mon xavier vous allez partir avec toute
la compagnie créole vous allez voir
alors on devait avoir chez nous on
devait avoir un car et je vous jure un
minivan et le minivan est tombé en panne
jamais on a fait novice ailleurs il est
tombé en panne le minivan donc vous
allez partir avec une estafette je peine
à trouver un truc hein je vous jure que
c'est vrai et vous allez voir vous allez
avec la compagnie créole vous allez être
je peux pas vous dire avec quoi mais il
va avoir des trucs très très bizarre
dans le dos de la piste a fait on va
vous retrouver dans 5 à 10 minutes dans
les cela fait vous ne savez pas où vous
allez mais ce que je peux conseiller
métal
mettez un loup apparemment c'était pas
le look jean luc lemoine parce qu'il a
une petite tête
bon à la barre de c'est pourquoi rester
comme ça ja des gones au parec la
conquête
opale aux palmas et ça va
quand tu étais pas
et vous allez vous rendre dans un
instant mes chéris conseiller régaler
nos patrons s'en vont regarder et ça
vaut regarder à une année au formulaire
oui d'accord alors il ne sait pas où ils
veulent pas trop mais vous inquiétez pas
il va faire là soir il va faire la fête
toute la nuit
young il valait par tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que c'est pas pourquoi
parce que on l'a peu vu un autre car il
ya des animaux avec lui ah bon non il ya
des ânes ya des cherry a marre et vous
allez voir je sais pas pourquoi moi je
sens que pour faire la fête
le meilleur endroit ça reste quand même
chez un des chroniqueurs en hausse à
plus de langues qu'on a les clés de la
maison blindant trouve nay
et qui va les faire là et qu'ils
allaient faire la fête
on va aller faire la fête là bas vous
verrez avec toute cette petite équipe
voilà donc je pense que ça va lui plaire
voilà haut niveau continue à être votre
ami chez qui c'est qui vont aller vous
pouvez gagner une xbox tient chez le
chroniqueur que vous pensez hashtag chez
les chroniqueurs et on vous appellera
pour gagner il ya combien 8 x box à lui
moi je mets un pied à chaque de leur
bouquet dollars mots c'est pas lui
mais j'aime bien vous dites vous mais je
pense que quand vous allez voir ce qu'on
vous a préparé vous à dire vous auriez
mieux fait d'aller chez moi un vrai y
aller en fait parce que juste avant
qu'on démarre la chronique
je voudrais vous montrer juste une porte
une porte et peut-être que quelqu'un va
reconnaître son appartement
regardez l'annoncé par dejan patron
n'ouvrait pas il ya une fatigue elle
fait énorme je vous le dis il ya des
animaux dans la cuisine
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quoi rêve moi
qui suis là
oui
en quoi mon chéri qu'est-ce qu'il était
persuadé qu'on n'arrête pas de me dire
des buts à l'heure huawei
camille vous reconnaissez votre porte
alors oui mais pas du tout des portes en
bois massif comme ça il a plein tu es en
chalet camille à quelqu'un chez vous bah
y'a personne mais je comprends même pas
qu'on pourrait avoir laissé y ait
quelqu'un t'a chien dégueulait chez moi
la haye à quelqu'un chez vous la hap à
mon avis elle avait les cambrioleurs
alors qu'ils sont faits passer pour vos
parents yakhi chez moi y'a pas une part
chez moi mais qui nous a ouvert l'an non
y'a personne non les personnes qui m'ont
fait aimer aux parents mais c'est grâce
à eux qu'on est rentré 0 choper des clés
de mes parents dans le sud et gare
ouvrira la corde en un instant ça tombe
bien un truc je suis un des seuls à voir
ton adresse
la passé alors des mecques aussi pour un
déménagement tôt j'ai pas grand chose
j'ai pas grand chose vous inquiétez pas
on ouvrira la porte dans un instant j'ai
hâte de voir l'état de l'appartement de
camille combal
on va être bien quoi qu'est-ce qu'il ya
bébé on a vécu tellement de choses là
dedans berisha leurs droits des animaux
et ou quoi il ya des animaux et où il ya
des animaux il va passer une bonne
qualité les gars là quoi comme chez nous
est ce qu'on peut me dit j'ai un canapé
rouge c'est une excuse
là
allez qualifie la vérité le pauvre a eu
peur je vous dis on a reproduit regarder
on à votre hall d'entrée votre immeuble
c'est à l'identique mais ça n'est pas
chez vous dans ça on n'a pas pu le faire
c'est vraiment chez vous là c'est
vraiment cher allez on y va on commence
à coller je suis mal pour camille sarah
kamini lizard
j'avais peut-être qu'en fait-on m'ouvrir
ya rien c'est que du mytho pas les
animaux non mais peut-être camille
peut-être que je vous fais marquer
depuis le début car rien il se passe
rien chez vous il faut quand même penser
à ses voisins qui regardent par l'oeil
de boeuf équivaut la compagnie créole je
veux pas
la contradiction
mais je sais qu'on se calme un peu
anachronique de bertrand guay souligna
jean luc lemoine qui mariait juste après
les questions cafetière à strassen plus
montré une photo
parce que gilles verdez va réaliser un
énorme défi en dernière partie de cette
émission
gilles vous avez réalisé dé définir dans
cette émission non non non non c'est bon
vous partirez parce que sexy en haut de
l'immeuble de type c'est bon c'est vrai
arrêtez-vous l'angoissé c'est ça les
yeux bandés non non parce que il ya des
problèmes d'air non mais c'est vrai
vraiment essayé les lunettes
jack c'est vrai mais c'est quoi comme
apparaît ici de quoi indécent c'est le
plus grand toboggan du monde au le lpg t
m dans un instant sont des milieux soi
que je vais mourir de rire
camille est ce qu'on voulait voir ce qui
se passe chez vous franchement non
xavier est où ma femme et vous avez à
dire si vous m'entendez fait un signe de
la tête
apparemment il m'a dit je mets donc en
ciel et je sais lire sur les lèvres du
patron on a quand même le seul patron
qui a contrôlé l'histoire john wade en
4ème de belloy est tout jeune je garde
toujours tout jeune tout jeune et déjà
est déjà si talentueux jazz et on voyait
que camille combal à une porte en chêne
véritable armée sur la faute de la
partie ça chez vous quoi un fait d'un
rien un restaurant raclette ou quoi je
vis dans un resto d'altitude allez c'est
génial on y va avec un petit coeur allez
bon xavier on va pénétrer chez camille
combal avec la compagnie créole c'est
parti mon radio entre on va voir ce qui
s'y passe c'est vraiment j'ai vu un cas
il faut le dire aux téléspectateurs
vraiment chez moi
sarah shaw can il a les clés de chez
vous lui tranquille à la vie c'est à
dire au dessus et camille combal
bravo les bayahi l'aja qu'on verrait de
portal
a riga
ça va c'est quand même ça
l'ambiance écrit tous ces gens il ya une
odeur
alain dans la cuisine des animaux
thiam
les boutons
ces fois là bas des laisser faire la
fête dit la vérité et laver ses trois
années mais bravo les gars passera toute
heure d'accord voilà il s'en foutait la
compagnie création de toutes les fautes
à cabinda
on est habitué
mettons les gars quoi les motos et les
gars c'est un truc d'altitude mais enfin
quand même on vous a pris une chambre
d'hôtel pour ce soir bien sûr quand vous
abbas qu ils vont inciter à bas toute
l'année mais les voisins ils doivent
être entretenues web ait des gros
problèmes avec les voisins combler
l'occurrence ici c'est géraldine c'est
pour ça julien vous allez avoir beaucoup
de demain avec ton syndic qui va
t'amuser
bon bah voilà donc laissé qui tous les
gens c'est chaud on allait survenir en
bas de chez vous c'est déjà on les
connaît pas pour les aime beaucoup sa
défense tout ça d amour de gars ils vont
revenir chez eux
allez mon cas mais vous allez vous
coucher banon là